oh lee jung 3
nicht super viel lebensfreude da mein
erster teil hättest du so mega gut ankam
habe ich mir gedacht doch auch einen
zweiten teil von einer herzlich
willkommen wir heute seine runde nur
eins ich muss als erstes zeichnen und
kann mich entscheiden zwischen einem
gips einer spinne und der atomuhr er ist
ja klar was sie nehme eine spinne hat
auf jeden fall ein gesicht und zwar so
[Musik]
wer hat denn da jetzt noch nicht die
stimme er die sprachen lernen dabei
alles sei mit dem smiley und gewicht
aber jetzt bekommt die spinne beine von
daher bin ich jetzt mal gespannt wer
jetzt als erstes der liebe gezeigt hat
jetzt was das wort ist ein bisschen
länger
es sieht bisher ist sie aus wie ein auto
ist das quatsch das ist quatsch das ist
100 prozent frau bestritt
hö
was ist das
was soll das sein sorry aber was wenig
bruder jo was machst du was ist das
[Musik]
apropos brillengestell meine lieben
freunde das hat eigentlich gar nichts
damit zu tun
aber morgen um 15 uhr bei meinem
geburtstag launch dieses kissen im lucas
ab 1000 mal jede bestellung bekommt
einen eingang okay es geht direkt weiter
das ist ein dreieck dreieck najib chebbi
zeichnet jetzt ein wort und es hat nur
vier buchstaben also ich weiß nicht was
das sein könnte mit weniger buchstaben
für mich immer schwieriger als wenn es
viele sind als die zeichnet 3d raum
[Musik]
einem cabrio
der ist eigentlich da vinci aber egal
ich will zurück meine lieben freunde
wer da nicht raum errät ok haus könnte
natürlich auch sein das stimmt aber er
hat sich extra 3d mäßig sein also nah
wie du bekommst von mir auch antwort
also wirklich irgendwie habe ich das
gefühl dass seit der letzten episode
viele dazugelernt hat kummer wie sie das
bett noch richtig rein zeichnet
krass das hat nur zwei buchstaben ich
glaube das ist ein ei das schauen was
die leute hier so schreiben gesicht
müssen schiebt dort wahrscheinlich mit
zwei buchstaben gesicht kreis schreibt
er die bio dennoch einer kreis
vielleicht schreibt schnell zeichnet
jetzt irgendein bild und ich glaube das
ist einmal ein strich schmerzt es ist er
hat den strich weg gemacht
es ist schon wieder ein strich autobahn
was das team hat jetzt ein wort und zwar
in orange das könnte das könnte diesmal
nah zu sein
[Musik]
irgendjemand hier
si
falls ja
es ist einfach vor mir was also muss ich
mich jetzt auf jeden fall heftig beeilen
das wort hat wieder nur vier buchstaben
tab ist der enter
das ist dank
was ist denn das vier buchstaben mit www
navi navi hat es vor mir
rewe city wahrscheinlich ist dass
supermarkt dollar die erste runde ist
vorbei von daher bin ich jetzt wieder
dran bezeichnen und ich male entweder
eine braut einen vault boy oder stechen
ich glaube ich ich zeichne die braut wie
kriegt auch wieder ein richtig schönes
gesicht
zackig 22 brüste kriegt sie ihre füße
ihre arme und ein kleid mein gott sky
harz navi harz jahr kommen dann kriegt
ja noch so rothe schühchen hier zeigt st
[Musik]
ruft man will mich jetzt an ich muss
gerade braut zeichnen
ich hab' ich bin erster ok ich hab'
platz rücken holte sie ist dran
bezeichnen die macht mir am meisten
konkurrenz hier auf den ersten platz von
daher muss ich das jetzt relativ schnell
erraten
das ist ein gitter nee das ist ein
gefängnis oder das hat nur fünf
buchstaben was kann das sein
immer mal die jetzt wieder also die
hatten ja auch schon relativ gut gemalt
eigentlich das ist eine einkaufstasche
nee nee wieso denn verschiedene farben
okay das checke ich jetzt gerade nicht
also es ist auf jeden fall irgendwas mit
waschbrett herr matthias schmidt
[Musik]
falls du denn ein waschmittel die
garantie jetzt das nächste wort es ist
lila und besteht aus sechs buchstaben
ich habe keine ahnung was das sein
könnte ich eben eine kerze eine kerze
hat fünf buchstaben luca du analphabeten
[Musik]
lucius rasierer mal die jetzt gerade
etwas und verzeichnen einfach ein
dreieck warte ist es einfach ein dreieck
dreiecke dreieck 3 auf mein gott nicht
um 33 eck
runde nummer drei meine lieben freunde
ich habe die auswahl zwischen navy mixa
und pelikan ich würde sagen ich zeigen
einfach einen pelikan das konnte ich
schon damals in der schule mal ganz gut
also erst mal ein jahr hier im schnabel
so ist der kopf hier das ist der körper
so bekommen die beine die haben hier
hinten haben wir auch noch einen kleinen
pischel dran so mache ich jetzt mal das
auge da mache ich aber diesmal so dass
man auch wirklich erkennt dass das auge
ist
sieht so ein pelikan aus ich habe das
ganze jetzt noch mal gelöscht also ich
glaube im pelikan hat doch irgendwie
hier zum langen schnabel oder nicht hält
den muss auch erkennen so
so ist der und dann läuft er noch so
sein ding besitze billig an der welt
[Musik]
jeder hat erraten um ein gott sich es am
zeichnen und sie malt irgend etwas
gelbes beziehungsweise ich glaube es
sind haare so wie es aussieht
von daher sage ich einfach mal es ist
eine prinzessin
gleich gehts auch gar nicht um die haare
wieder hat denn die ein oranges gesichts
sie drei wochen später der junge frau
nicht ich muss mich jetzt auf jeden fall
ultra krass konzentrieren emma zeichnet
hier gerade und zwar irgend einen roten
ball um ein gottes medizinball
das ist muss comcom potters rechts noch
was ich sein englisch grad 2000 jahre
später
kaugummi kugel deiche doch vielleicht
ein mond wo man sieht das ding rein
steckt aber ich muss das jetzt gewinnen
alter fällt wohl bitte komm du musst
jetzt so zeichnen das nicht dass er rate
allen orange orange passt nicht er hat
alles wieder gelöscht und zeichnet
wieder irgendetwas oranges sag mal bist
du irgendwie was wir denn da
was soll das sein schreiben alle
mandarinen es passt ja nicht
l am ende
oh mein gott so viertl gewesen meine
lieben freunde das heißt es könnte sein
dass ich jetzt den ersten platz
zurückerobern
ich bin leider immer noch zweiter
allerdings so 60 punkte hinter citi was
es ist es apple ja damit den ersten
platz zurück haben ich bin fünf punkte
vor ceo bei gott ich muss jetzt die
nächsten beiden runden beide forsten ist
sie abschließen ich weiß nicht was das
hier sein könnte das ist sondern
aufgaben aufgang untergang n'est pas ist
dass sonnen sonnenlicht sonnenstrahlen
horizont und das ist jetzt auch schon
die letzte runde fürs heutige video es
ist wieder eine person die absolut ein
komplexer beschützen miss internet hat
jetzt weiß ich auch irgendwelche roten
strichen damit zu als ich habe absolut
gar keine ahnung was sich irgendwie
dabei die gerade erreichen wird aber
wahrscheinlich hat sich einfach kein
internet allerdings ich glaube die city
kann mir den ersten platz nicht mehr
wegnehmen
ein paar sekunden später mein gott okay
es ist ja das wort erraten scheiße
[Musik]
die könnten ag er ist erster
hcc und na'vi ich bin vor euch an der
stelle mich dass heute ich wieder ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch diese volkes capsule
mit der lucio gefallen hat dann zeigt es
mir gern mit einer bewertung unter dem
video schreibt mir gerne und in die
kommentare
ob ihr auch einen dritten teil
vielleicht nächste woche haben wollte
dass ich wieder mit euch mal wenn ihr
mit dabei sein wollt dann folgt darauf
instagram ich heiße dort laser luca und
dort post ich immer ganz spontan haye
kommt rein in den raum wenn die
mitspielen wollte die bereits zu beginn
gesagt diese skizzen hier lernst morgen
um 15 und lukasz ob jeder bestellung
bekommt eine signierte autogrammkarte
dazu ich gehe jetzt packen
[Musik]